[Applaudissements]
c'était le but c'était vraiment le but
de se faire plaisir et de faire plaisir
aux nombreux spectateurs
m
[Musique]
oui
à
c'était vraiment le but de se faire
plaisir et de faire plaisir aux nombreux
spectateurs
je sais pas si je refais ça encore
indéfiniment je les ai déjà dit l'année
dernière mais c'est vrai que c'est un
énorme plaisir d'abord de pouvoir faire
un beau rallye où les spectateurs
justement été extrêmement disciplinés ce
qui a fait que ça s'est bien passé c'est
important je pense qu'on des
organisateurs temps pour nous aussi pour
les compétiteurs que de trop bien et
donc voilà si c'est vrai que conduire
ces engins exceptionnel c'est quand même
quelque chose de fabuleux et je peux
vous garantir que c'étaient de vraies
sensations de vraies émotions et je suis
vraiment ravi d'avoir passé un bon
week-end c'était pour moi presque des
vacances et même des grandes vacances ça
me change de mon quotidien et ça me
rappelle surtout de très bons souvenirs
et pouvoir convenir d auto aussi
exceptionnelle c'est génial
[Musique]
non
oui
on
et
on s'est fait plaisir
mon devant c'est pas possible se sont
dédoublés via ces championnats du monde
s'est auto donc bon on dira ce n'est pas
du jeu mais bon voilà
et sinon s'est fait plaisir on s'est
bagarré avec la r5 au début et puis bon
bain après on a essayé de gérer notre
allié au mieux et terminer ce rallye sur
un podium c'est magnifique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
non
[Musique]
moi
non
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]